- Let's do an example
on the performing translations exercise.
Use the translate tool to find the image
of triangle W I N for a
translation of six units,
positive six units, in the X direction
and negative three units
in the Y direction.
Alright, so we wanna go positive six units
in the X direction and
negative three units
in the Y direction, alright.
So, I click on the translate tool.
Click on the translate
tool and I wanna go,
so, I wanna go positive six
units in the X direction.
So, I can pick any point
and go six to the right
and everything else is gonna come with it.
So, one, two, three, four, five, six.
So, I did that part, I
translated positive six units
in the X direction and
negative three units
in the Y direction, so everything
needs to go down by three.
One, two, three and notice,
I focused on point N
and this is it's image now,
or the image of point N,
this whole triangle is the
image of this entire triangle,
the triangle W I N after
the transformation,
but you see that every point
shifted six to the right,
six to the right and three down.
This point over here, six
to the right would take you,
let's see, it's at one
and a half right now.
It's X coordinate is one and a half.
It's new X coordinate is seven and a half,
so it's X coordinate increased by six
and it's old Y coordinate,
or the original Y coordinate
was six and now, in the image,
the corresponding Y coordinate is three.
So, it has, we have shifted it down three.
So, we see that that's
happened to every point here
and we're done.